hi everyone Sal here from Khan Academy I
am back in the walk-in closet where Khan
Academy all began
socially distanced obviously the entire
globe is going through a very unusual
crisis right now and as part of that
crisis you know people are worried about
three things they're worried about their
health both physical and mental health
they are worried about the economy and
then they're worried about how do we
ensure that kids can keep learning with
now nearly a billion kids that otherwise
would be in school are now out of school
in order to protect people from this
virus and all of us here at Khan Academy
as a not-for-profit with a mission of
providing a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere recognize that it's
our duty to step up in this crisis we
never could have foreseen this type of
situation but we want to be there to
support you support students parents
teachers to get us through this
situation so we've always been working
on resources starting from pre-k with
Khan Academy kids that covers math
reading writing social-emotional
learning all the way through the main
Khan Academy website an app that goes
from kindergarten through the core of
college including middle school in high
school in math English language arts the
sciences we have history economics we
also have official SAT practice for you
but as we saw the school closures began
to happen over the last few days and now
it's accelerating we realize that we
need to do more so on top of that we are
publishing resources for parents for
students for teachers to be able to
understand how to navigate the situation
just recently we published schedules so
that students parents and teachers can
structure students days and there's
different schedules for students of
different age groups and we are doing
daily live streams so that at this time
of social distancing we all can feel
connected and make sure that there were
we're there to support each other and
the team here at Khan Academy is very
focused on making sure we can support
y'all through this crisis we're seeing
the server load increases or the
engineering
is reassuring me that we think we have
it but I also and we're also exploring
other ways that you we can support you
and and we're looking at ways that we
can get more help for folks things like
that I will remind folks that we are
not-for-profit even before this crisis
we were operating at a bit of a deficit
and so if you're in the position
especially as our demands on our server
and our costs are going up as people use
us more if you are in a position I hope
you could think about supporting us
philanthropically I want to really thank
Bank of America just over this past
weekend they stepped up they realized
that our costs were going up that we had
to have a better response effort so they
have helped us there but we need more
help so for any of y'all out there who
are in a position where their individual
or corporation if you're finding use out
of the resources we're providing please
think about making a donation to Khan
Academy it will allow us to support the
nation and the world as we go through
this this very very unusual crisis
together last but not least I just want
to say as one human being talking to
another you know this is a new frontier
for all of us but I've been very
heartened by the humanity that I'm
seeing in everyone everyone is just
trying to help everyone else as a human
being and I'm confident that if we just
do the next right thing one step after
another that we're all going to be able
to get each other through this situation
thank you